Oh
sup everybody I'm in Vegas Cooter's
gonna make my decision the entire night
you know they say start out lazy and got
crazy
okay so we just got done hanging out in
the lazy river it was lazy as we're
gonna pregame to go out do we chug beers
or do we take tequila shots you got that
shame you've got the B whoa wait you've
got the key to Oh baby smooth all right
so we are in the hotel right now we're
headed downstairs to gamble three more
beers should be going TP yeah okay let's
go back and get beer okay sure why not
why not looking looking run Lila's boys
ready set okay so we're headed
downstairs we're gonna go gamble 20
bucks I'm gonna put 20 bucks on red and
hopefully I get 40 bucks mind if I sit
right here going for it I'm going all
the way we're just going all the way
I'll join you soon you're joining me on
red yeah that's what you're all doing
red let's see what happened
Twitter you did it red was what I got I
got 20 extra marks free Twitter look
into you look how cute you are
you look cute bhai you get me rich you
get me rich
this way
well guys turns out the negative 5 place
you can't bring your phone in so how am
I supposed to show you the fun so we're
not going instead we're gonna either go
to a pinball Hall of Fame or zipline
between the real dirt hours if why don't
why I hate that Fred I iron very wet
eyes god dammit well boys is my
nightmare let's do it want to get out
there you'll feel better oh yeah you
think so so we're headed to the 51st
floor to ride the zip line oh this is
awful Oh No
left oh my god might be your wrath here
we go
oh my goodness
we did it
I made a friend I made a friend with
Dylan Dylan would never ever let
anything happen to him are dealing with
never we're doing
Dylan solid we go you know sometimes
you're near Vegas you gotta take that
revolving door for spin let's I can't
get out I don't either
all right so run away to the Luxor work
damn look at the head of statues serene
almonds now that we ordered smoothies
this was not a third Pole no this is
just a decision we're kind of getting
too drunk you nasty now we're going to a
club
I was sure I was sure we'd get puppet oh
sure where's is it sexy love
you know so we're on our way tomorrow
son
MGM Grand Rock the next Hakka science
it might all just be too much you know
what my Vegas just might be too much
we gotta come yeah so
everything they said
what is papi yeah oh my goodness
gracious that's crazy that's uh hope
nice keep you fighting ana what is this
amount of food I don't know what's
happening okay let's go that was helpful
just well guys we did it
you know did the entire night up to
Twitter until the end movie sort of went
rogue but we most think we we used
people tweeted all the suggestions I
just couldn't use calls we just were not
in good enough shape that's the truth
we'll see you next time Twitter